[Music]
but this week we've got it - beautiful
that's one sorta - I spit mmm dusty keep
it in your mouth pearl okay everybody
shut the [ __ ] up and bad PR stud take it
away
Tiffany so for our first story there is
this 44 year old mother of four from the
UK 44 with four year old Chinese 44
years old with four kids that are 4
years old no that are divisible by 4 4
kids fought quite the quad-core triplet
only 40 people fingers and 4 children
and the 4th grade for ever done one and
she went on this British daytime show
called
this morning claiming that she's just
too beautiful to find love oh let me see
what this [ __ ] looks like better be
finest fun man oh man what do you mean -
beautiful - find love so this is dawn
where is she we're right here right
there the Asian man in the back room
looking on maybe that's a bad picture
that's he another picture I have a few
where do you take a patient I think well
first of all in order for you to be
beautiful you have to have a neck like
what the [ __ ] is going on [ __ ] yeah
another fixture whoa
- beautiful so she's saying that she's
just too beautiful because she looks way
younger than her age what is she 70 if
she's 70 she's [ __ ] fine before she
looks 44 she has kids age ranged from 17
to 22 so she's saying that she looks 44
even her kids Jan was falling in love
with her and like trying to get with her
and she's just like Oh
she dresses young though no she's not
ugly yeah she's not I'm not like to be
what she's clean he's too beautiful for
me or like mom you have to like clown on
people like this anybody who says
beautiful she's beautiful right there
she went on the show for years there's a
whole lot of 44 year olds on Instagram
and on in Hollywood that I look really
hot
like what's the Victoria Secret model
named Heidi Klum Heidi Klum now with her
age is catching up but she still finds
[ __ ] yeah and [ __ ] JLo hello I know
Hall does she now be 240 she's almost 50
she's almost yeah you were the funny
thing about JLo is why she doesn't
attribute her looks to just you know
obviously there's good genetics but this
[ __ ] pissed me off she goes somebody
asked her she goes well how do you look
so young she goes it's simple just drink
water and sleep yeah yeah everybody
drinks water and sleeps you [ __ ] ho
or maybe she drinks a lot of agree with
what he's saying like yeah we can all
add an additional what two hours so we
can go look like you we're not gonna
[ __ ] yeah I'm sure it's a lot of help
I'm pretty sure she goes into like a
dumpster and finds fetuses and rubs it
on her face like there's no [ __ ] way
it's crazy how young she'll always
genetics to genetics cuz there's there's
ladies that still drink and smoke and
sleep like three hours a night in their
30s but they're still hot yeah can they
eat like Burger King there's also anti
aging women Mexican tart like Mexican
target chrimbus or some [ __ ] and he saw
her in person
he says she looks better in person than
she does in videos who did cleave oh
yeah he says when she walks by you could
smell her presence like I knew she
smelled good she looked good I've always
said I bet jail smells bomb you have you
seen people they just look like these
smells yeah there's other people that I
look at too and I'm like I bet their
spit smells
specific you know I mean how come JLo
looks better with age I need those JLo
genes because the in living color Jade
law wasn't as hot she wasn't she had so
much baby fat I think yeah also she had
a little like chole on this tour yeah I
mean like she knew how to like put on
her makeup now you know so much Auto
Ricans yeah so we show you guys a video
clip of dawn on this show it's a quick
clip she looked like Letty some [ __ ]
fast severe yeah a little bit yeah
various reasons number one obviously I'm
very attractive woman obviously number
two I look very young number three I'm
very fun and I'm not your typical 44
year old woman or fortune fittest and
that younger guys are messaging me
wanting to take me out but they just
want me because I'm hot they want me to
send them pictures of me looking good
and they wanted to cut my body and then
they say somebody just dropped in my
pockets that sounds like insecurity that
that's not confidence that's that's
hiding her that's ego that's hiding your
insecurity yeah that's that's
overcompensating for delusional that's
yeah yeah but that's she might have been
really hot when she was younger and
she's [ __ ] holding on to that [ __ ]
yeah because copper's is still based on
reality
United mean that's not reality for her
to say listen I'm too hot like when I
walk up to the Sud the Sun goes away
from me you know it'd be like that she
thing that she gets a lot of messages
from older guys than that she's like not
to them because she's like all these
older men they don't take care of
themselves you just want me for my body
cuz I look hot and then she's also
saying that she has a loving young guys
coming at her but that she's saying no
for the same reason cuz she's like I
just want to find someone that loves me
for me like they are going to cuz you're
not that attractive like I'm saying
that's a good illusion I feel like all
women in their DMS have guys going after
them constantly guys are always trying
to [ __ ] there's guys in my day I'm
trying to come after me do
you ain't special [ __ ] [ __ ] I get big
pigs weird but yeah so a lot of viewers
of this show they just ended up tweeting
at the show saying like what the [ __ ]
like looking that beautiful as a curse
like [ __ ] your personality is
disgusting no one's gonna want to date
you after seeing that show I think
that's why people are saying that she's
delusional
cuz it's almost like someone that has
six figures and they're saying that
they're too rich to have a good life but
it's like if you really were that rich
like you're a millionaire a billionaire
there's no such thing as like a too much
money problem and there's no such thing
as I got too hot problem because even if
let's say we open this thing right that
she was the most beautiful woman I've
ever seen even then I still call her a
[ __ ] but at least there's some
deniability in there it's like okay I
could kind of see that you know this
woman she average she's not like what
she's claiming she looks like the host
of like a luau or something yes
like I would cast her for the head
hostess of a luau I like Paradise Cove
yeah not even the top Louella though
it's one of those $35 luau
yeah yeah so apparently now she wants to
come and live in the US and see if she
can find you should come to LA you're
like a la3 wait wait where's she from UK
oh you know I think she's presentable
she's not ugly but at the same time
she's no supermodel oh for sure she's
gonna be a traffic controller in LA no
she looks like she does the thing for
like elementary schools and I don't know
and I think it's her personality that
drops her down like anyone that self
promotes and has to say that like yes
obviously I'm [ __ ] beautiful
yeah oh my god that that just drops your
beauty down so many want to punch him in
the face mm-hmm
look I would never had a woman but that
might be the first cuz if she was going
around saying like I like taking orphans
in and giving them a home then all of a
sudden she's like three points hotter
yup oh yeah humility goes a long way
lady so for our next story McDonald's
was facing some
easiest backlash over a situation a
Chinese McDonald's no like I would not
like that McDonald's that we know I
heard people were waiting in a line like
the McDonald's in China yeah I'm pretty
sure it's nothing like Sichuan flavor it
was like a sriracha flavored well
they're claiming it is that you want Oh
we'll see about that
so this is said the Korean guy that's
really teriyaki flavor know what I'm
saying is like you know every time like
an American fast food company says is a
certain ethnic flavor it's not I've
tried curry flavor in France it was okay
yeah but that's France no I'm talk about
American I said that bastard Isis it
they bastardize a lot of flavors man and
I'm telling you it's not it unless that
[ __ ] I eat it at my whole mouth goes
numb it's not such one they're making it
for the universal palate I mean did you
try their sriracha burger I don't like I
don't like any sriracha flavored
anything I like sriracha by itself
don't sriracha flavor my [ __ ] though
that's true I never really liked
sriracha flavored things I like to put
sriracha on things yeah you know a
sriracha mayo don't like just give me
sriracha and if you have Mayo in the
sandwich maybe I'll add this right to it
I don't know yeah so this so McDonald's
first released their Citroen sauce back
in nineteen eighty eight ninety eight to
promote Mulan Oh came out and that was
only obviously for a limited time just
for the promotional offer list you want
problems yeah even know that yeah I
thought Mulan was Mong so then Rick and
Morty have you guys heard of that [ __ ]
yeah so Rick and Morty they really get
bored it is funny okay so they uploaded
it or they had an episode where Rick he
travels back in time he goes back to
1998 and you're saying he's just saying
that like the the thing that I want the
most is that such a want sauce from
McDonald's it's the greatest in the
world so I'm gonna show you guys a clip
from that episode
where Rick is waving a pickle Rick where
are we going to the day it all began and
ended the moment that changed everything
yeah I'd like to get a ten-piece
McNugget and a bunch of the Szechuan
sauce like as much as you're allowed to
give me in 1998 they had this promotion
for the Disney film Moulin where they
where they they created a new sauce for
the McNuggets called Szechuan sauce and
it's delicious and then they got rid of
it and now it's gone it's the only place
we're gonna be able to try it it's in my
memory Rick you're doing this bit while
your brain is melting okay all right all
right they pop re popularize it exactly
this issue on teriyaki dipping sauce
what though they mix two countries oh my
god and teriyaki Japanese you [ __ ] yeah
so then they always mix it up the new
Chinese bulgogi sauce No
and so McDonald's will announce that for
one day only they will have these sauces
at specific locations across the country
and they own babe totally underestimated
how many people wanted it because they
were saying that certain locations only
had 20 sauce yes so they were people
they were like we want to sit you on
side so here's a video of a location
there's cops this is the LA location
they really specified what is it that
good I've never tried it
so fix it and your mom I think I know
that play yeah so this is the Rick and
Morty version yeah and then immediately
when people got their hands on it they
started posting on eBay and they have
bids like got 300 bucks for one packet I
saw this guy dipping a sauce for 10
bucks each on a nugget
so people were standing around him and
he went bit and then he got 10 bucks
yeah is it that good have you guys tried
it I think it's the rarity the record
morning thing too because I kind of want
that hmm I want to just keep it and put
it into a picture frame yeah so then
McDonald's got a [ __ ] son backlash
because it was only a little bit
available and then not because it's
Szechuan [ __ ] teriyaki huh it's the
Rick and Morty thing then yeah I did
it's the Rick and Morty fan and so now
McDonald's announced that they will be
bringing them back and not in limited
quantities but for during the winter
time but they're gonna come back to all
locations not just the like location why
that how did that [ __ ] better be
delicious 20 sauces 22 one location
that's the that's ridiculous I don't
know if it was for every single one but
they did mention like at one location
they only had 20 of the underestimated
how many people like maybe they didn't
reach that good when they first brought
it out so they were like are I well for
the 20 people that want it no but there
was even a petition going around like
the people saying like they wanted that
sauce back like bad so finally McDonald
is like we listened to you not really
20 is low I need at least like two or
three things so that's only good enough
for like six to ten people that's true
yep what's your favorite sauce and I
like all of them
barbecue honey no I asked you [ __ ] bro
there's a honey sauce yeah a honey
mustard no it's just honey here's what
honey on it yeah I can see that working
with your chicken nuggets yeah I never
tried that [ __ ] you gonna make Donald
ask them for pure honey and what is it
is it that you still didn't even ask the
question she did it
what's your favorite sauce honey it's no
what's your favorite sauce not the thing
that you created the chicken nugget song
that's meant by McDonald oh I thought it
was no chicken nuggets no it's just a
break I need for the team to use it the
dipping stuff or is it the packet what's
your favorite stuff a glass of milk
mine is the McDonald sweet-and-sour
because there's no other sweet-and-sour
that tastes like McDonald's sweet laughs
I'm saying they bastardize the flavor
but that's just delicious
yeah well are we trying to any of their
sauces wait what is there there's
barbecue here's a honey mustard honey
mustard there's a honey honey mustard is
cool too there's one that you got that I
had never heard of sweet chewy that's
the one I would get okay then maybe
that's it what they did you try curry I
didn't have tried the curry one I try
curry and uh you know what
French food when I was in France is
sucked but McDonald's though they have
an actual cafe in there yeah legit cafe
well freshly baked yes
this is it and freshly baked bakeries
you know when you're saying a word and
it's coming out and then someone else
says it's and then you changed your the
word to that no you do that a lot is
funny
we are freshly baked bakeries
for our last story there's this viral
video going around in China you see this
tour guide he's walking her across the
glass bridge in China and then all of a
sudden the bridge starts crackle wonder
god what did we say when that first came
out it was made in China and it was made
to crack it is three thousand eight
hundred and seventy one and it is oh
it's on the eastern face of the Taihang
Mountain
yeah hey inhibit hippie China that's
weird hey babe hey babe
Habibi I don't even know what a [ __ ]
that is anyway lieutenant I don't trust
Chinese stuff Oh hold on to the metal
you crazy that lady didn't give up turns
out that this is like a marketing stunt
uh
so he didn't know that it was fake well
the thing is a lot of people are
speculating that towards the end of that
video you can see like he kind of cracks
a little smile and then the fact that
the lady didn't give a [ __ ] like it
seemed like it was kind of staged like
his reaction was staged no you can't be
doing a marketing stunt like that
what are they marketing a new movie
broken broken bridge that's the worst
way to market it though cuz I think
they're trying to get people to come but
then they're showing you how it's
cracking which is gonna do the complete
opposite and deter people that's like
doing a [ __ ] like the brand new
Hyundai Elantra the airbags never work
today I thought it was like a whole
movie that they're a trend like they
made a movie about broke King bridge and
then you fall down oh you know like
those natural disaster movies like the
volcano fall it's funny because in 2015
this other glass pathway in Henan it did
crack and it was closed after a lot of
people are panicking but then later
they're saying that oh you know it's
it's good don't worry about it they even
did this thing or like media stunts
where they would drive like huge SUVs
over the bridge oh that's dirty but for
this specific
the administration sent out an official
apology letter for that video going
viral saying that it's merely in effect
and it's not anything real and that they
were just trying to make it like fun
like the bridge more fun you're about to
die let's go yeah that doesn't make me
want to even believe the sounds of the
glass breaking and everything but it's
too close to what you expect that's the
problem yeah you know they're saying
that they're not gonna get rid of it but
they're still gonna leave it in case
other people want to go and experience
like what would it feel like if glass
bridge that's [ __ ] crazy dude and why
would the other so the other place where
the glass bridge actually cracked
they're like look don't worry watch as
if we drive this four-wheeler across it
after they fixed it yeah yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] cuz I'm not gonna want to go on the
bridge after they did something like
that you promise eyes the bridge now
[ __ ] they shouldn't make anything out of
glass in China okay we should send all
the steel and my titanium of the world
to China just so that can you can last a
little bit longer last time we made a
mistake but this time it's a jog don't
worry that's so funny because imagine if
they with if they made the Golden Gate
Bridge like that and then a car like
just [ __ ] fell through and it's like
you know what guys we [ __ ] up one time
but this time is gonna work - it never
happens America I don't think there's
any amount of money in this world that
you can get me to do that liar if I had
a complete I can't do it
100 million I can't do it a hundred
million I can't physically do it I
probably would pass out oh yeah I mean
like it I would have to stay waiting you
freak out yeah I think I would actually
pass out on that thing seeing the that
they have one of those here like at an
Indian Reservation on the Grand Canyon I
want to do that because when it's when
it's made here I trust it with my life
to American hey guys thanks for watching
that last episode did you love it I know
you did but guess what you can also
follow us on our personal social media
accounts with the links in the
description box below so go follow all
of us now to watch more videos check
them out there
[Music]